this is the i think the most inspiring
story of the week pro-abortion
protesters in dc out on the streets
again
uh they promised a summer of rage but
that kind of fizzled out instead they
have settled on more of a
summer of um
mildly annoying people and so that's
what they've been doing and they were
doing that in dc they were out blocking
traffic
and sitting in the street blocking
traffic and and um the protesters were
given multiple warnings by police say
you got to get out of the street we're
gonna have to arrest you and they they
stayed there because they wanted to get
arrested because it's all publicity
stunt and um and so the police ended up
arresting a bunch of people including 17
house democrats who were there for the
pageant
and were taking part in it none of them
were put in jail or anything like that
none of them were charged with anything
serious or anything at all but they were
arrested technically because that's what
they wanted that's why they were there
um that's why they came out to
participate in the stun
and that's why video went viral of
representative alexandria caser cortez
she of big booty fame
being marched away
in handcuffs let's watch this if you
haven't seen this footage yet
you have to see it um so let's play it
now
[Music]
okay so you see her being marched away
there by the cops
and she's in
she's in handcuffs but actually the
handcuffs are invisible because okay and
then she raises her fist there so she
forgot she forgot that she was
pretending to be in handcuffs and she
raised her fists and said oh oop sorry
um but you know so they're invisible
handcuffs and they also allow for full
range of motion
that's possible
now some are looking at this footage and
they're saying the empress has no
handcuffs
but i look and say
wow what an inspiration because listen
even if she isn't technically handcuffed
and we don't know that
because can you prove that she didn't
have invisible handcuffs can you prove
it do you have evidence that that
they have not invented invisible
handcuffs and put up you don't have that
evidence
but even if she wasn't okay
even if she was even if it is as it
seems that she was pretending to be
handcuffed
she is still handcuffed by the invisible
restraints of systemic racism and the
patriarchy and toxic masculinity okay
i think that's the message here this was
a this was a symbolic
gesture meant to communicate all of the
many ways that she is oppressed
by our society you know when you use the
bathroom you always uh shut and lock the
door behind you right i would hope that
you do you don't want some random person
accidentally walking in on you so why
would you let people walk in on your
online data using the internet without
expressvpn it's like going to the
bathroom and not locking the door you
weirdo did you know that your internet
service provider like comcast or verizon
knows every single website you visit and
what's worse is they can sell this
information to ad companies and tech
giants who will use your data to target
you expressvpn puts a stop to all this
it creates a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet so
that your online activity can't be seen
by anyone i use expressvpn on all my
devices it works on everything phones
laptops even routers
so everyone who shares your wi-fi can
still be protected even if they don't
have expressvpn best part is using
expressvpn it's as easy as closing the
bathroom door you just fire up the app
click on on one button
big red button actually just click on it
and you're protected simple as that
expressvpn is the world's number one
rated vpn by techradar the verge and
also countless others so if you're like
me and you believe that you're on online
activity is your business secure
yourself by visiting
expressvpn.com
walsh yt today use my link and you can
get an extra three months free
and then you can also see it there's a
different video with ilhan omar where
you see her
getting
carted away as well
so you see you see alexandria cortez and
then you see ilhan omar
also with hands behind the back
yep there she is
she has not only invisible handcuffs but
an invisible cop also that's escorted an
invisible cop is escorting her away in
invisible hand restraints
these people will stop at nothing to
keep the squad down they're pulling out
all the tricks invisibility cloaks and
everything
now the joke's on you if you if you do
think this is this is this was all a
stunt okay if you're more of the cynical
pessimistic type and you think this is
all stunt
um if you think that this was that it
didn't work well that's where the joke's
on you because
um they did this
to get headlines exactly like this from
abc says just in representatives
ocasio-cortez omar and other house
democrats arrested an abortion rights
protest at the supreme court and then we
see the photo of them from the front
hands behind the back no mention that
they're choosing to stand like that that
they're faking the handcuffs uh that no
mention of that
so they got the photo up they wanted and
that's all that matters
most people will will never read far
enough into it to find out that she
faked it most people aren't on twitter
so they're not going to see that twitter
was making fun of it for a day and
having fun with it um so most people are
going to see that this is what most
people will see they'll see just that
image
representative queso cortez arrested at
abortion and they see her just standing
there with hands behind behind the back
she got what she wanted out of it
just as most people probably still don't
know that she was crying over an empty
parking lot down at the border at the
very beginning of her public career
[Music]
it makes it easier to pull stunts like
this when you have
you know
the media as your propaganda arm well
before you go uh hit the subscribe
button and ring the bell and while
you're at it if you want to go watch or
listen to my full show head to
dailywire.com and subscribe you can also
catch my show on spotify apple podcast
or wherever you get your podcast so go
check it out now i demand it
your compliance is somewhat appreciated
you